we're moving into you from sets to
sequences to what happens when you add a
sequence together which we've already
discussed is called a series right so
what I want to do is call you my back
because this is going to be the first
day that we look at this morning and
we're going to exercise what I remember
Sigma notation okay
simulation is a wonderful little tool
for taking something which is very long
and just boiling it down into the
smallest okay so what should to remember
we did this really really briefly last
time but you see in Sigma notation
before so what does it mean right
for starters why did it choose the
letter the Greek letter Sigma why what's
the significance of that it's it's the
Greek letter it's what course wants to
out S which is the abbreviation of this
zone right so we're adding things up
hence series okay so the whole idea is
that we're adding things up everything
we're adding up looks like this this is
the format it's in if you like it's a
little bit like function notation right
like this thinking is going to be a
function all whatever let our printing
room has been chosen okay
that's what they all look like in this
first example and squared which in
Squared's do we want to add up come on
when N equals 1 buzzer all the way up to
N equals 5 right so this is
automatically defined for a whole number
values here right so we're not doing
like any 1 and 1/2 we're going 1 2 3 4 5
ok so I can simply you know read this
out will write it in like full form and
then we'll start to simplify it ok so be
that they're on this form I'm going to
go one squared there's the first one 2
squared 3 squared all the way up to what
I call my upper boundary right so I've
got my upper and lower boundaries which
are here and here my start and end
points okay so we've got that right now
okay this is just this is just the
number isn't it right like this is
what's simplify a little more okay can
someone tell me what this is equal to
what are you I've seen that's 5:30 55
yeah looks good to me okay
so just know right all of this fancy
schmancy stuff over here all it's equal
to is a number that's all that it like
now let's have a look at this next
series that's written in Sigma notation
but the most frequent thing that you'll
come up with that as your starting point
is N equals 1 because first term right
but there's nothing saying it has to
start N equals 1 it can start anywhere
it likes so that's a fairly you know
ordinary value but the started cake was
205 wanted to let's have a little bit
happy turns by the way am I gonna have
good morning every times they're gonna
happen three very good and then I turn
to then turn three then turn four it's
important to know how many times I'm
going to have in a in a series if I
start and put in cables - yup seven
times two minus one that's 13 isn't it
13 now without actually evaluating you
should be able to tell me what the next
term is just by thinking you could
packing right cuz um see how I said this
is color function notation right your
ear I said there are three different
ways that you can define a sequence
which means which kind of implies there
are three different ways to define a
series right so what you've got here is
function notation it's just like the
formula good morning this is what the
antenna looks like this is team and/or
team k if you like whatever pretty me
we've got there 7 K minus 1
what kind of sequence series are we
producing yeah good I'm adding seminary
time which makes us an arithmetic
progression right this is going to be an
AP so my next term is gonna be 20 and my
last time is gonna be 27
good morning that's so so that's all
there is to it 13 plus 27 is 40 plus 20
is 60 ok so a big deal right now I would
point out a couple of Kings
firstly these two things that I have on
the board right I'm taking a secrets and
I'm adding all up I'm adding some finite
number of terms ok so we call both of
these things these are
we call these partial sums this isn't
really important phrases is gonna come
back to us later it's a partial sum
because you're taking part of a sequence
and you've added up that part right the
partial sum of a sequence partial sums
were really important tool that's the
first thing I want to point out from
this example the second thing I want to
point out is can you see my first secret
a shin has ends in it and my second
Sigma notation has k's in it what
difference did that make so the way I
went through the question/answer didn't
make any difference at all right in fact
it was just that good morning it's just
a label it's just a label and that label
disappeared as soon as I started putting
numbers you write as it were like I
could change these decays I could change
these two ends the other song is just a
number at the very end so that little
variable in there that pretty room it's
just a placeholder it's just a
placeholder it's just gonna get swapped
out there I'm putting it in for a second
in until I put in what I really would
okay now that that placeholder idea that
the name of the variable doesn't matter
it has a particular name then what we
call it's a funny name dummy variables
it is very scientific isn't it right
it's something that's just gonna get
swapped out it doesn't matter what it is
I could call it whatever I like I could
say from from friend and equals one two
Brenden squared right that's it doesn't
matter what my label is it's gonna
disappear in a second anyway
Brenden squared that's a scary okay